I think in terms of today's China that
the Cultural Revolution was both a
terrible time for a lot of the people
who experienced it but I think it has
set the stage for China to really be
able to change in such a quick fashion
that by this desire to create a new kind
of modern-day china by getting rid of
the feudal system I think what it did
was it freed up chinese society to be
able to adapt so much quicker to the
demands of today and so i would say that
if we were to look at the chinese
situation that it would really be the
Cultural Revolution at ten year period
from 66 to 76 as the major catalyst for
what we see as being success in China's
kind of post-industrial inflation
mainland China has always been a very
strong attachment to being Chinese but I
think it's almost an irony that the
societies that we might call a belonging
or belong that belonged to greater china
like Taiwan and Hong Kong and even
Singapore I think that they have an even
stronger attachment to being Chinese and
in that way have often replicated or
created the circumstances for the
continuation of traditions in a way that
we don't see today in mainland China so
being Chinese i think has many different
layers to it depending on whether you're
in mainland china or whether you're even
here in New York it's a very complex
thing but there is a sense
ever of being Chinese as belonging or
having a kind of strong attachment to
mainland China as a place even if it's
an imaginary place I think that the
world doesn't understand that most
Chinese people feel that the last 200
years of Chinese history have been a
terrible kind of moment in Chinese
history that Chinese people have a long
have a strong understanding of their
five thousand year history and in fact
if anything many young people talk about
today's China now and the future as
being a renaissance of Chinese culture
and Chinese history that this might in
fact the 21st century might be the new
tongue dynasty and the tang dynasty was
when most people think of as the height
of Chinese civilization so I think that
that's really what people maybe don't
quite understand is that it's not just
about economy and getting wealthy for
Chinese people it's also about this huge
kind of sense of cultural pride that
they want China to succeed
I think that China has recognized that
the United States is very important to
their future and I think that they
acknowledged it in all sorts of ways but
I think that we also i'm in china
sailfin the leadership in china has to
also recognize the importance of the
environment in its policies and you know
I often hear advocates of Chinese the
Chinese government say when they talk
about the environment that they use the
analogy that you know all the first
world nations have developed and ruined
their environment and it's almost like a
room of smokers where the China comes in
and they all say you can't smoke meaning
the analogy being that of course all of
the first world nations have already
developed and they don't they want to
somehow hinder China from smoking or if
the if you push the analogy further in
terms of in terms of actually developing
and I think that that and some in the
Chinese government recognized this
already but I think that this will be
really something that will affect the
future of not just China of course
because of its size